In all of this, changes in size, changes in language,
changes in speed, or changes in the program itself
are all obstacles for record, replay, reproduction
of graphical user elements.
A better option is to have the GUI elements themselves do the recording.
That is, when I'm clicking in here
the search button knows it has been pressed, and what I am recording
right now is not the fact that I clicked in this particular area of the screen,
but what is recorded right now is that the search button has been pressed.
Likewise, if we enter text in this field, what will be recorded is that
in the URL GUI element, the text foo was entered.
This way, if anything in the resolution changes or if the position changes,
the events will still be tied to the GUI elements,
and therefore, our recording becomes independent
of the actual rendering on the screen.
This of course is also true for rearrangements as long as
the identifiers of the GUI elements stay the same,
we'll still be able to replay earlier logs even though many details,
in terms of the rendering, have changed.
The best capture replay tools offer facilities to record
and replay at the low levels.
That is, mouse clicks and keystrokes,
but also facilities to replay at higher levels.
That is, directing some input specifically toward
some element of the graphical user interface.
For web pages, the Selenium Toolkit offers
a nice mix of multiple abstraction layers.
Check out what kind of tools are available for your specific environment
and test them thoroughly before making a purchase.